my comic was getting turned into a
television show I don't know how I could
be I don't know what what better thing
can happen you know television is really
kind of your mid level like mid budget
movie these days you got your
blockbusters and everything in theaters
but special effects have gotten to a
point where like lost and heroes like
that's your 40 million dollar picture
now you know it's on television so I
think that it's television kind of grows
you're going to see a lot more comic
books on TV and I'm really excited about
walking dead has always been about the
characters it's really kind of masking a
nice dramatic character study with
zombies to make it kind of more
interesting but it's really all about
Rick Grimes and these people trying to
live in this world and survive and and
the things that they go through and how
living in this world changes it's a
little grin I'll admit people are dying
it's very sad I've been watching dailies
I'm an executive producer so I'm
involved in the process I've been out to
the writers room I i I've been working
with them like shaping the season i
wrote the fourth episode so I mean I you
know I'm there every step of the way I
mean luckily Frank and Gale Anne Hurd
and all the people are cast and they're
doing such a great job I don't really
have to step in and do anything but it's
it's going it's going along really good
I've seen a cut of the pilot and it
looks really good and I couldn't be
happier I mean I think it's going to
really blow people away it's something
that people aren't really seeing on
television right now or possibly ever so
I think it's going to be a really unique
television experience it's good to be
able to kind of see what the show is
starting at which is the start of the
book and then seeing where it's at by
volume control for Rick Rogers are
vastly different character who's been
through a lot of pain and suffering and
we've got to see how that's shaped and
molded him as a character and these are
our loved ones and you know our
relatives and you know friends and
neighbors and you know it's not their
fault that they're dead and it's not
their fault that they're trying to eat
you I mean it's good to kind of view
them in a sympathetic light you know
zombies are really cool i mean i
understand that vampires are a little
more romance
that kind of stuff but I mean given the
chance you'd be surprised
I'm having a good time
you